you you re you reached out to me because
you saw that i interviewed stanley
krippner right
yes correct
cool
but i'm not into parapsychology
um but we stan and i are both in the
same
society for consciousness studies
which is where we met
yeah
nice
yeah
and i and consciousness is i'm not a
psychologist
i stumbled into this
oh i don't know 25 30 years ago
totally serendipitously
uh one of those things where just one
you know thing followed on to another i
basically i'm a cell physiologist
and i was
i for my entire
career as a bench scientist i was
looking for
some way out of the circularity of
physiology
and i finally discovered it after many
years
in realizing that um i had amassed
enough data myself and and other
colleagues who
made a living out of studying lung
development which is very important as
you know obviously um
i have i have the line here that i think
um
it actually is what piqued
uh my interest
most in your linkedin bio and i'll read
it right now
turns out that alveoli are the
structural means by which the lung was
modified to increase oxygenation in
response to the metabolic drive for
vertebrae evolution
right yeah yeah and that that's
uh it that's remained i mean it's it's a
given
um we've been we've been remonstrating
remonstrating i guess is the correct
word by a french physiologist
that henry said in 2014 in a paper about
physiology he said we make a systematic
error in defining physiology based upon
function that's a tautology it's
teleologic it's never going to get us to
where we want to be
so the central question then is well
what is physiology
and so um
uh i and a benchmate of mine in in
in the laboratory i trained in at mcgill
university in montreal had discovered
that um
the way that pattern formation and
embryology actually transpires is
through cellular communication uh that
was just emerging stan cohen for example
won the nobel for his discovery of
epidermal growth factor that's an aside
though but but what that actually did
was i just publi i just wrote a paper
about the lattice work of physiology the
lattice work of physiology and the
latticework of the cosmos are basically
one and the same yeah um and i say that
is because
uh lynne margulis a former professor of
mine as an undergraduate i formulated
the symbiogenic principle of how it is
that we evolve
um through the assimilation of
factors in the environment that pose
existential threats for her the
transition was
the assimilation of bacteria that then
formed a mitochondria at the time she
had limited information now it's a
well-given
recognized fact but the point is that in
doing so in assimilating factors from
the environment
uh we have been backed into
uh having to ascribe to the same laws of
nature that the cosmos does
that's where our consciousness actually
resides
um
and so i'm not a pan psychist
that's the idea that everything is
conscious that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that we have we have affected the
consciousness of the physio of the
physics of the cosmos
by
uh utilizing
factors in the environment a classic
example
is iron and the heme
protein that
carries oxygen around the circulation
and red cells iron
ordinarily would be a potent oxidizing
agent that would kill us but in fact we
make it useful
and that goes on and on and on um so
i think that the one thing that is
unique about
so the 200 papers i've published 100 of
them actually relevant directly to
cellular revolution
and the uh seven books i've published is
that
every other
investigator every other person who has
considered
physiology the origins of physiology
consciousness has looked at it in what's
referred to as a synchronic way
in real time
what you need to do is you have to go
across time and space and time
that's diachronic
and in so doing what you do is you shed
the material aspects and what you're now
focusing on is the energy the energy
flows that are actually the essence of
who we are we mistake ourselves as being
material beings i i'm fully in agreement
with
um whitehead
process uh philosophy uh whitehead
alfred north whitehead was the one who
said that we are basically energy matter
is a is a epiphenomenon
and i don't mean to sound um mystical
although it may sound that way
but i but even in in the process of
embryology which
kind of has been my bread and butter as
we look at the process of embryology
from the fertilized egg
to the
morula to the gastrolog
ultimately to the offspring
that's actually a series of high-energy
phosphate exchanges so that's why i say
it's clearly energy exchange and that
doesn't cease until we die basically
physiology is the homeostatic control of
that energy right
yeah so um i think that's an important
concept and i it's not easy to um in to
to
get your head your head around initially
but i think it's important
in really trying to understand
why we are here and what it is that we
are
so in my laboratory for example at ucla
we do epigenetic research so epigenetics
is everything but the dna code itself
and we study the effects of
parental cigarette smoking on childhood
asthma a well-known epidemiologic
epidemiological
phenomenon we've shown that nicotine one
of the three thousand components of
cigarette smoke actually causes
childhood asthma
and it can do so
for at least four generations
um and the way that that works is
through the um
assimilation of of nicotine in the
environment nicotine is a yellow oily
substance and it sticks to all these
surfaces and um
and then so the organism so an infant
crawling around on the floor is going to
pick this stuff up and it's going to
absorb it and what happens is
biochemically it uh gravitates towards
the egg and sperm in the ovary
intestines of
the organism and it changes the dna
readout by changing the biochemical
um
there's a it's not the dna itself is
changing but the way that the dna is um
translated into rna and then to protein
so um that's been a real learning curve
for me in terms of understanding the the
direct acquisition of information from
the environment which is
uh 180 degrees out of sync with
darwinism darwinism is really an
epiphenomenon it's just describing a
reproductive strategy whereas what's
actually happening
is this internal selection for
structure and function
through
these epigenetic mechanisms um
and so i actually
have considered the real possibility so
so what i've done is i've i've worked my
way back
from complicated physiologic structures
like the alveolus of the lung glomerulus
of the kidney
bone skin brain
all the way back all of these
physiologic traits can be traced all the
way back to the unicellular state
and
in fact i think that the way that
epigenetics functions in a way where the
developing organism
is
informed of the oncoming
change or changes in the environment
it's kind of like insider insider
trading is giving a heads up to the
organism that there's there's change
that has to be adapted to
um so basically what i think is actually
happening is we don't go from adult to
adult we go from zygote to zygote
um
through the epigenetic mechanism and so
uh it's a very different paradigm in
terms of understanding uh the way in
which we have it
essentially adapted to an ever-changing
environment the universe is constantly
expanding our environment is changing
and we in turn as organisms
have the risk the
responsibility if you will to perpetuate
the species by changing as a as a
consequence of all of that in a way
which is commensurate with
what actually is occurring in the
environment
did that
nice yeah covered so much ground there
cool
so
let's cover some topics together
and let's start with uh you listed
symbiogenesis so lynn margulis and also
just in general from an abiogenesis
standpoint this feels like
one of the most crucial
moments for consciousness to sort of
look at its source
on its home planet
and to
reflect on the unity
of itself
yes
and so the symbiogenesis component of
again taking different parts of cellular
evolution and then merging them into the
most recent example of
what we've evolved to these 30 trillion
cell
organisms i love reflecting back at that
source point of this earth's
proliferation of life because it makes
unity a no-brainer it makes oneness a
no-brainer
and i feel like that is such a crucial
way of perceiving science and
spirituality merging as one thing
so i'd be curious to hear your take on
that first how we can basically use a
biogenesis
and cellular proliferation
life proliferation as a
as a no-brainer for us to understand
unity
i did a critical experiment about
25 years ago in which i had been funded
by the nih to study
a specific
hormonal mediator of development
parathyroid hormone related protein and
um it's an interesting uh molecule
because it's regulated by the distension
of of the cell when you distend uh a
lung cell a bone cell a skin cell that
expresses this gene it increases the
expression of this gene
um if you delete it you don't get
alveoli in the lung you don't get
glomerulomerular formation skin
formation it's critically important and
in fact it was critically it was
critical for the transition of from
water to land about 500 million years
ago and i thought to myself well this
sounds like a gravitational effect so i
beg borrowed
um
bombed this contraption that nasa has
approved a houston
aerospace spin-off company that makes
this device in which you can put cells
on
cefedex beads that have a
certain buoyancy and you put them into a
this contraption with culture medium and
that you put it in a centrifuge then you
spin it and you're emulating
microgravity
and in that condition lung and bone
cells show a
dramatic decrease over about an
eight-hour period in the ex in the mrna
production of this pthrp gene you put it
back into unit gravity these cells then
like become normalized again so it
showed that it wasn't that as cells were
dying they just were reacting to a
microgravitational
environment and in the same paper i
actually got some bones from rats that
have been flown in deep space and you
see the same thing uh astronauts suffer
from osteoporosis for this very reason
because there's loss of tension on the
bone and that and that causes a loss of
that pthrp mrna expression in the bone
and that's why astronauts develop
osteoporosis for example
but the point i'm trying to make is that
gravity as one of the four forces
generated by the big bang or what
theoretically was the big bang
is essential for life
it's also been considered to be
essential for planetary formation so now
you have the same force determining
planetary formation and the inhabitation
of those of planets by living organisms
so there's a
consilience there of of the two
processes obviously life came after the
planet planetary formation by several
hundred million years
but still in all the same gravitational
principle as there
um
and so
that's where i think the the unitary
aspect of this the singularity of this
uh
mechanism comes from is through this
common
mechanism of gravity affecting both
non-life or abiogenic
[Music]
forms and biogenic forms as well
beautiful
yes and i've also been adamant about
sharing that the
bounding function in cosmology is a
critical component to life evolving
and developing and reflecting becoming
self-aware and reflecting on itself
so meaning gravity are these bounding
functions so rocks planets orbiting
stars
that are bounded by gravity to so that
basically the map you could say is
limited
not actually but it up gravitationally
speaking creates a massive limit so that
way there's only a certain amount of
land on the planet that can be explored
it makes it so that the conscious agents
you and i plus our audience
that they must interact with each other
because of this bounding function
so if the map of the land was unlimited
to start
then there wouldn't be as much of a
pressure cooker or forcing function for
the agents to interact with each other
so that plays another big role in
gravity uh not only on the cellular
development like you indicated but also
as a bounding functions for the agents
to actually need to
interact with themselves
so that
mm-hmm
and going even deeper
because the way i had gotten back to
the unicellular state
and that question about gravity was
basically looking at emerging properties
in the reverse direction in the in the
process of physiologic evolution and
saying okay
this event occurred what were the
precursors of that because that's the
way this works it's there are precursors
which exist and then they're utilized by
the organism not consciously but
unconsciously to address
emergence
[Music]
and so the question arose as to where
symbiogenesis came from
um and i thought to myself well so i
know that based upon einstein's field
theory that if you if gravity
impinges on a curved surface it produces
energy so that would have explained how
uh so i'm trying to understand quantum
the quantum mechanical principle and say
okay so that's where the energy for
quantum entanglement occurred in those
protocells
for the to give rise to symbiogenesis as
this process of taking stuff from the
environment and utilizing it for uh to
to
to to self-benefit
um and it also um
uh
encapsulates both the local effect of
gravity
on this on the protocell itself and also
the non-local reference to the gravity
in the cosmos so you have this local
non-local relationship
and that in turn references quantum
mechanics which everyone acknowledges
has to be at the basis of both physics
and biology but no one's ever really
been able to um
determine how the quantum mechanical
aspect of biology
uh has come about because they've only
looked at it from a synchronic
perspective i'm talking about a
diacronic approach
and i do think that's important because
that then creates a level playing field
for for everything we talk about
um
and in fact i went one step further and
said okay so where'd the quantum
mechanics come from and that's
referencing the particulate nature of
the aftermath of the big bang
and so my thought has been if in fact
the big bang is occur is correct oid
it's not may not be absolute but
something a cataclysmic event did occur
um that in fact no one's ever suggested
that well there must have been you know
based upon newton's third law of motion
an equal and opposite reaction that's
where homeostasis comes from
that's the equal sign in every balanced
equation physics chemistry and biology
alike and homeostasis is essential for
biology absolutely and for all
processes because that's the only way
you get matter you wouldn't have matter
in the cosmos if you didn't have that
that reverse
reaction
to the to the um to that eruptive
process so that and homeostasis is
critical as we both know for
physiologic um
for the physiology of of the cell and
and
and above
right so that's how it all comes
together
including the quantum mechanics
um
and the
and the physics
uh i'm sorry the so you have that
interface between the quantum mechanics
and the classic newtonian mechanics
which is always
um it's referred to as um
there's a term for it where you have
this
you know people question how you can
have an interface between quantum
mechanical properties and the messy
newtonian mechanics well it's through
biology i think that biology is really
this the initiation of everything that
we experience
prior to the existence of life the
formation of this topological structure
it was all
you know what bone called the um
implicant order it was just you know
this
infinite um
space
without any meaning it's only once life
occurred that it conferred
the you know bombs explicit order
meaning to the existence of everything
including the
non-non-biologic i would submit
i don't know if that makes sense but but
i think what context for example i think
that
we normally think of mathematics and
physics as being innate but herself
published a paper on the origin of uh
geometry in which he said it's not
innate we express it
onto a piece of paper and make nice
drawings and then we internalize it but
it actually exists in the cosmos it
doesn't exist within us and so that's
that non-localization kind of idea and i
think that math physics and maybe even
the arts exist in the in the cosmos and
we just
reference them through our physiology
which is kind of a
somewhat metaphysical well it's a very
metaphysical idea but i think it helps
me to understand so so for example the
cellular communication principles of
physiology are what i wrote a paper on
that being the origin of language
language comes to us very naturally um
children do it you know they develop the
ability to to express themselves through
language and then print language etc etc
quite naturally mathematics is much more
difficult and i think it's because it's
not innate you see what i'm saying it's
outside of us
and so there are people who are good
practitioners and they get it but it's
not an it's not part of that our innate
uh understanding of who we are
mathematics is
um an abstraction
so anyway i'm just trying to suggest
ways in which this model actually
uh circumscribes a lot of things that we
haven't understood up until now in a way
which is holistic and not you know
having to use different um
principles at different levels and and
you know sort of
make stuff up it's not made up this is
all mechanistically inter uh
interdigitated and and introdu
interdependent yeah okay so
totally yeah
yeah the interdependence is
something that i
um
feel very
much is a cornerstone to us
understanding unity and oneness and also
the
like one of the best ways for us to
recognize that everything
has a
string that is endless
of
how it came to rise
so
not only
us
as individuals
have this endless string of ancestry
that gave rise to us this great chain of
being
but even the little
strawberry that you eat
has this great chain behind it of how it
came to be
and of just an insane amount of
interdependence and so that's a good way
to be able to
recognize um
oneness unity there's so many other
great things that um that you've shared
that i would like to
for us as best as we can to address
so yeah so one of them was the
the lattice work of the cosmos
so the macro and the lattice work of
physiology
so the micro
are
the same so go ahead and unpack that a
little more for us
so when i talk about the latticework of
the cosmos
so when a star generates light
uh starlight it actually produces matter
and it produces matter the first 36
elements of the periodic table in a in
the sequence consistent with the atomic
mass so it's consistent with the
periodic table
and that's important because
for years i i tried to find a
at least an analogy if not a homology of
the same origin for evolution and then
it struck me uh i became friends with a
well-known
uh chemistry professor who's written
several books on the periodic table uh
and so what you see in the both
evolution and in the periodic table is
you have both the synchronic and the
diacronic processes
at right angles to one of them literally
so and what happens when that when that
occurs according uh uh to um
uh highly of a student of bones who
wrote a paper in 1984 with frascura is
when you have two harmonic processes
that uh are at right angles to one
another and one another they they
generate cyclicity
so that's what's happening in the so the
periodic table of elements is both
synchronic in the sense that it's like
the alchemical physical characteristics
of the elements but it also references
the big bang because it's also the
atomic mass of those elements in the
same way that
ontogeny development and phylogeny is
the same thing they're they're the
short-term and long-term
history of the organism but then when
you reduce both to the cellular
signaling mechanisms that i describe you
can uh superimpose one on the other
freely and you get a wave collapse as in
quantum mechanics
uh and and so there too you see that the
the imposing of the ontogeny
or regressing the ontogeny against the
phylogeny at right angles gives you the
cyclicity of the life cycle
and that in turn
is in tandem with the vector of the big
bang
and i think that the closer we
approximate that vector the the the more
smoothly the life form
exists within space and time
i think that that's the art of life is
the problem solving of trying to
move ever closer to that asymptote
because you never reach it you're never
going to be in the implicat order
perhaps until you die maybe when death
is represented by merging with the
implicant order i don't know that's too
that's too that's not scientific for me
any longer i i i stipulate that
everything i say everything i've said
is based upon experimental evidence and
i'll stick to that because that's the
only way that i can really understand i
can differentiate between
um inductive and deductive reasoning
okay so yeah
cool
so
i also
want to explore this together that
we are energy you said that earlier and
that that was um uh alfred whiteheads
um
yes
and that obviously that's also very
deeply rooted in um many of the mystic
traditions as well
so why don't we go ahead and um play on
that also so if it is in fact the case
that
this is energy with itself
can that simply be a way to
describe what
the universe is
i would say yes
i mean the the
place i'm at
from a
[Music]
a reductionist
understanding of what's going i've
gotten this close as
recognizing this
unicellular
state
in juxtaposition to the singularity that
is thought to have existed before the
big bang but the question is
what what is that relationship
i think it's like the red queen in alice
in wonderland the cell is
running as fast as it can to remain an
equal poise and it's it and its uh
reference point is the singularity but
in saying so i would say yeah that's all
about energy right
the energy of the of maintaining equal
poise
referencing
the parent structure
of the cosmos
so yes
it's all about energy yes it is all
about energy and how energy is
um
presented
in a way where you can continue that
that vectorial
um
magnitude and direction of change that
was generated by the big bang
yeah there's uh several other um threads
i feel like pulling on this one a little
bit more so
so it does seem to make
most
sense
to then
speak of
biology
as a
like you described a sort of uh
like interface or um
medium we could say
for
uh
you could look at it a couple ways one
of them is for quantum mechanics and
newtonian mechanics you could also look
at it from
um
a homeostatic angle as well so similar
with the
the polarities that are in a rhythmic
balanced interchange of sorts
so not only with
the simplicity of the
blood sugar
homeostasis but also with things like
the male and female polarities on uh
planet earth another just simple
examples of this
so then
so i really like how how uh biology can
be seen as like also the vehicle
for
life
to express itself or for whatever the
big big bang is
call that god or the one or infinity or
whatever you want to call it for it to
use biology
to explore itself to express itself
how do you feel about that
yeah the closest i i hear what you're
saying
i think the closest i've come in this
context is i guess it's like proof of
principle that consciousness does exist
it's it's a it's an expression of
consciousness without without the the
living
the life form
uh i think it's less obvious that
consciousness
it constitutes the cosmos but once you
have the life form
um expressing consciousness then it's
unequivocal right
i guess that's what i would say so so
the way that i put this together in
terms of the uh the configuration of
life itself so it's well known that uh
lipids are produced by pulsars the earth
the pro the the primordial earth was
covered with water that was produced by
these snowball-like asteroids that
delivered ice to the surface of the
earth before it had an oxidative
atmosphere and there were there were
lipids in the in those asteroids as well
we know that for a fact
and so when you have gravity impinging
on so this lipids are in interest are
interesting molecules because they're
amphiphiles they have a positive and a
negative
charge on either end and so when gravity
impinges on those uh like those lipid um
lipids floating at the surface of the
water they'll cause them to
stand perpendicular to the surface of
the water
with the negative charge downward
because it's hydrophilic in the positive
charge charged and pointing upwards
now and when they pack together they
have the property of reducing the van
der waals forces these weak forces that
cause surface tension and once you have
enough of those lipids packed together
you get the formation of micelles or
liposomes
they're it's a net it's it's what they
use to deliver the mrna for the moderna
and pfizer mrna vaccine for example it's
it's a it's a commonly used method in a
biochemistry lab you wet and dry these
lipids in a test tube and boom you get
these protocellular semi-permeable
membrane structures
um
but the point i'm trying to make is that
that then offered the opportunity for
things to happen within that protected
space within that
semi-permeable membrane
and i i've
posited that that that's where the first
principles of physiology emulate from
schrodinger's negative entropy
um
chemiosmosis as a way to maintain
that negative entropic state because
otherwise it will just the energy will
just dissipate
um and the third property is homeostasis
when you put those three components
together
in association with the protocell that's
the beginnings of life
but it's also the beginning of
consciousness
in the way that we understand it
so again i i would go back i i the best
i can do is because it's not an easy
thing to understand
that relationship between our human
consciousness and the consciousness of
the cosmos other than to think that
we're just
exemplars we are the manifestation the
the organic manifestation of the same
thing that the cosmos is constituted by
it's the one
right
yeah i guess in the terms of the
of the mystics
but it is a unity and and and uh and i
published a paper on the singularity of
the cosmos i do think it is there is a
singularity
not not kurzweil's technical singularity
but the singularity that the you know
the greeks talked about 500 years ago
yeah
right heraclitus i guess yeah
right
so you know we intuitively understand
this
i only and i've had discussions with
buddhists when i lived in uh los angeles
i won't no longer live there i live in
on the east coast
trying to
make find common ground with buddhism
because we're talking about the same
thing
they don't require my science they
already understand all of this however i
think it's beneficial to understand the
underlying principles from a
a rational standpoint because then it
connects the dots with other humanistic
aspects of our
lives
in a more
um
in a more rational kind of way rather
than just believe you know it's like
christian morty when he says to david
bone and obama in 1984 at brockwood well
the only way you you can connect with
the cosmic consciousness is to
relinquish your ego ego is matter he was
telling bohm yeah you've got to
relinquish matter in order to get to
that energetic state of the cosmos
bone didn't come back with his
scientific sort of comeback which was
surprising to me but i think there is
one
and i don't mean to be you know
insulting
to people's beliefs but i do think
there's a you know obviously there's a
fundamental difference between between
believing
and providing experimental rationale
that you can then further test for
predictive purposes
so
as a scientist i prefer the
scientific approach as opposed to
just
merely believing or not believing i
think it brings more people in the tent
or people like me would come into the
tent
for sure yeah
yeah this is exactly why i'm so
passionate about the synthesis of
science and spirituality is because they
you have a an earth that has went
through a long period of evolution
and now the
emergence of self-awareness to be able
to reflect on its source on what it is
and why it's here
and
at this exact point is when there's sort
of a
a split where you have one side that's
super interested in consciousness and
the subjective and in how that is god
and how that is the one and on the other
side you have this focus on materialism
or physicalism and trying to dig into
the most particles uh but you can't
understand the particles without
understanding the whole but it's also
really important to see well why are we
creating separation why are we creating
a duality between consciousness and
physicalism or science and spirituality
when ultimately they're one
and so you can actually bring more
people as earth wakes up to what it
truly is we can actually like you said
bring more people into the tent
by
merging science with spirituality so by
coming at consciousness from a
scientific angle
um
so meaning like
another way to say it is coming at
infinity from a
explanation of what it is from a
scientific or a finite angle
um
so basically
the
the
i mean there's so many ways to take this
but um
but you're doing well
i'm with you
for what it's worth there's so many ways
to take it um
yeah if you if you have um
if you have an infinity
which is what this is
then it would never come to the end of
exploring itself never it's impossible
to come to the end of exploring infinity
so just most simply or logically put you
can't come to the end of exploring
yourself you will try endless
combinations of possibilities to explore
yourself
and in all different types of ways
especially in ways like in this case
with this universe let's say or with
especially this earth
is we fall asleep to an extent
to separation
and so we think we're separate from that
infinity from that one from god and so
then we develop a whole story a whole
narrative around being separate
and so rather than associating ourselves
or identifying ourselves as god or the
one or infinity we identify ourselves as
a finite separate biological creature
which we are at the same time
so
i as infinity will never die
but this specific individuated piece of
life is is mortal and is going to pass
and so there's a simultaneity that is
then
recognized that is very important
for sort of
like
just dropping the veil
and remembering what you are and then
sort of circling it back to the
simultaneity of it so
that's that's one way to put it is you
go sort of all the way to your source
um
and then you include
the you could say the body or the
limitation at the same time so you are
both something that is infinite and has
no limits and yet at the same time as
appearing as something finite with a
limit
and so it's a beautiful way to
be able to hold it all at the same time
and not get lost in one of those
there are some key elements that i might
mention here in the context of what you
just said i fully agree with you what
you said i think that we
we've gotten ourselves into this
situation for a number of reasons
not the least of which is that we began
in an ambigu ambiguous state of negative
entropy within the cell that's what the
life force really is at least you know
the schrodinger approach
and ever since then we've been making up
these myths and stories
to cope with our ambiguity that's why we
can understand uncertainty principle for
example we wouldn't be able to accept
that if it weren't for the fact that we
are of an ambiguous origin however we
are now at a state an inflection point
where we do have enough data to no
longer have to reason after the fact we
can now look in the forward direction
and we can see the predictive elements
of all that we've experienced in a way
where we can truly understand
who and what and why we are
that's important
um
if we are willing
you know and the big bugaboo is we're
all survivors right so we caught this
attitude well you know i got here i'm
okay dude so you know leave me alone but
that's not but that's not really what
the issue is with the issue is why is it
that there is this collective
consciousness why is it that there is uh
synchro synchronicity i fully believe in
young synchronicity
for all the reasons i've been talking
about it exists we just have to be able
to
have the capacity to sense it and to
react to it be open to it when it occurs
because it does happen happens to my
wife and i we've been together for 60
years
fairly frequently and i don't think it's
it's uh it's not causal it's just a
reflection of the
the the um holistic aspect of our
existence there was something else i was
going to say in this context
um blanken on it but uh yeah
um
i think that the time has come for us to
really
not unlike the um the removal of the
earth from the center of the solar
system uh hugocentrism we have to remove
ourselves in the center of the biosphere
we have to get over ourselves every
organism is conscious
it's it's just how they've adapted to
the niche that they're in
um and so we have to understand that
we've been given this gift if you will
of con higher consciousness if you want
to call it that the ability so in the
last paper i published on the mobius
strip nature of the cell membrane that's
what i was trying to explain is that
um
so the normal way we think of the cell
membrane is is this binary
decision-making process of in or out of
the cell for example however
this in the emergent way of looking at
the the evolution of the protocell the
cell
because of that lipid membrane
having hysteresis the ability uh when
this you know in its very origins having
these liposomes floating at the surface
of the water being heated by day by the
sun and deforming and then reforming at
night when things cooled off that's
hysteresis and what that did was
expansion and contraction trapped
calcium primarily calcium ions within
that
uh
space
and then our forebears figured out how
to move calcium in and out uh actively
through calcium channels that's that's
where memory actually originates from
it's not dna dna nucleotides are all
over the place of the cosmos it's the
cell membrane which is the the actual
determinant of life and once you violate
that cell membrane you're not talking
about biology anymore it's overly
reductionist and that's a huge mistake
that we make in my opinion
um uh jack shostak the nobelist at mass
general has shown that in a test tube
lipids can synthesize can synthesize
nucleotides nucleotides cannot
synthesize lipids for example so in
terms of the hierarchical relationships
lipids came first
lipid the you know lipid world was the
origins of life
um
but i'm getting ahead of myself so what
i'm trying to say is oh and so so this
idea of how the cell actually is
cognizant of its
pre uh
of its existence prior to being a cell
as these lipid molecules
is where i get this idea of the mobius
strip it's not a literal mobius strip in
the sense that you have a you know a
piece of paper and uh and you form a
uh you know and you form a um
you know a circle with a piece of paper
and then you cut through it and you
twist the end and now it has neither
inside or outside it's not a it's not a
literal mobius strip it's a figurative
mobius strip in which the cell
knows it has no inside or outside it's
it's open to the to the cosmos and
that's where our imagination comes from
from and i think that's unique to humans
it through
and i i don't need to go uh uh if you
want i can go through the rationale i
wrote a paper about the evolution of
of the central nervous system and and
how uh that evol emerged from um
largely from being uh standing on two
legs being bipedal freeing our four
limbs putting this huge cell uh
selection pressure on the central
nervous system
uh than that then generated through tool
making language and tool making language
being a tool um the capacity to
communicate as a as a derivative of the
cellular communication
properties it's a continuum yeah and so
so
so
uh imagination is really the key to what
how what distinguishes humans from non
uh from other life forms
we we can imagine
being in outer space and we've done it
uh clearly and we've lived in all kinds
of environments but that also puts us
into a bateson's double bind because we
get into situations where we're in
environments where we shouldn't be and
then we get into trouble so that's
maladap
maladaptive those kinds of things don't
happen with other organisms they know
their place they know their niche
and
and so they don't experience those kinds
of stresses we do
so so basically by standing on two legs
having you know the ability to text and
to make spears and all that other good
stuff
um that puts us at risk but it's but at
the same time it's what enables us to as
risk takers and with imagination to do
the kinds of things we do particularly
the gen the formation of
of
social systems and culture and the
ability to form printed words so that
you can exchange information from one
generation to the next
that codifies
all of our behaviors right
that's radically different from any
other species
so
yeah yep
yeah
that's uh
so what happened
as our brains got evolved and got bigger
and bigger it got too big to get through
the birth canal so as a consequence
we're born at about 25 percent of adult
brain volume so it takes us at least two
decades if some people never mature at
least two decades of protection by the
family extended family society in order
to mature
our brains
and so we're basically you know google
said we're naked apes we are we have
this area of broca in the cerebrum which
determines both tool making and language
and um
uh and the difference between us and
other great apes is we could we
naturally stand on two legs
but that also
generates
all these psychosis and neuroses
so you know it's a double-edged sword
but i do think my message has been that
we have to recognize that
once we've
um
virtually eliminated
the theology in our lives
uh formal um
religious practices
who else is going to step up we have to
but we're these immature juvenile great
apes and we don't want to accept that
responsibility
the reason that i
go out on the hustings and i talk to
people like you why i write books and
papers is to make people realize that
we're responsible for ourselves
we have to step up or you know we're
toast in my opinion so
yeah
i didn't want to sound preachy but i do
think that that's true
yeah i love how
we can see in the emergence
of the one
how using
cells and i love the recursive aspect of
cells and how they can then
be a vehicle for
self-awareness
and then i love how
that
then
like you shared we then use especially
um
communication to
be able to share
um information about what we are that
like symbol exchange between conscious
agents
if you will and
how
like now
more than ever
there's a
we could say a mass of
our
conscious agents in this collective that
want to know themselves they want to
know who they are and they want to wake
up out of separation and they want to
wake up to unity
and they want to have all basic needs be
met
they want to be able to be free and to
be playful and to be artistic and
entrepreneurial and scientific and
expressive
and
that
is screaming so loudly right now in
contrast to much of the matrix which
keeps many people in
cycles um of unconsciousness
and
so there's like this growing liberation
from that unconsciousness
and it feels fantastic catalyzing that
igniting that
and and it really and you use the word
imagination and imagination being so
critical as almost the pinnacle if we
could say of emergence itself
and that's totally resonates because
imagination
in a sense
is in a feedback loop with physical
and so the more that we imagine and we
occupy you could say an imaginative
state
of this podcast is going to go fantastic
that
i'm already living in the frequency we
could say in the imagination of
shambhala which is like this whole
planet being an awake and prosperous
spiritual kingdom
something along those lines and so then
my imagination like occupying that state
very similar you could say to the wright
brothers occupying the imaginative state
of the airplane
itself
and then that coming into manifestation
henry ford occupying the imaginative
state of the car that coming into
manifestation
elon musk occupying the imaginative
state of electric vehicles space rockets
that coming into imagination
reusable
all of that
it comes from occupying the state in the
imagination first and basically holding
2035
in 2022 consciousness you could say
and then people coming into that vision
and wanting to support that and nourish
that execute it
and so i love i love how you brought
that focus of uh imagination
and i love how you also
kind of created a nice um
analogy or metaphor um for us or even
just a comparison um which is between
the universe and the cell
and i find that to be
one of the most beautiful macro
microcosms possible because
the
used uh neg entropy so it's um order we
could say so entropy being disorder so
neg entropy being order or like
emergence of sorts
so the big bang and the exploration that
is the universe as well as the
cell
and the
the
exploration of the intracellular
components and then the
recursiveness into multiple cells and
then there further exploration and
differentiation as well and the just
that whole like fractal-like nature of
them as well as of
um
of the universe itself and how it does
generate into like a pinnacle of order
of emergence which is self-awareness
reflecting on itself and
it's just like
it's just so rich and nourishing um just
feeling into that and recognizing that
we are that and that
like
when you begin when one begins
associating their identity with this
like recursive nature of the cells and
with this fractal-like exploration of
the universe it
it uh it kind of like shatters all
limits it shatters all like
beliefs and assumptions about
oneself being
um so limited and so
and so contracted and so
um things like unworthy you know that's
one of the biggest ones is feeling like
one's unworthy or that one um is unwhole
in some way or and then all of the
compensation mechanisms come then they
fight for that worthiness or they fight
for the validation or fight for that
wholeness
and so when you can shatter these limits
does it make one feel so expansive and
it makes one feel so much more free and
so much more air-like
and then it that's really what um
drives you could say emptiness and pure
service because then you're when you
talk to somebody else you're not there
to get something from them but you're
there because you know that it's the one
with itself or god with itself and that
they're asking for something it's you
asking for something from yourself which
is typically something like how do i be
more free or how do i end my seeking or
how do i be more happy or more peaceful
and then you're just replying to
yourself without wanting to get anything
out of it and then that's how
this collective wakes up
i fully agree um
i wrote a paper so normally if you think
yes right
we normally think of phenotype
as a collection of
biologic traits that's not what it is
the phenotype in the epigenetic context
is agency
and so a lot of our human foibles
are
are
bastardizations i guess is the best i
can do
of these uh looking for these looking
for novelty in the environment changes
and small subtle changes in the
environment but that's what leads us to
you know overeating because bigger is
better in the wild
in the wild because you're less likely
to get eaten for example
or you know a lot of our behaviors are
really uh exaggerations of the normal
processes that we you know we undergo
that you know wild animals do it
naturally they're content with their lot
we're not and as you were saying we we
feel unworthy because we're not
recognizing we're looking at the
the wrong horizon we're looking at the
wrong
set of principles
we're looking at matter instead of
energy
what is going to maximally facilitate
the flow of energy
between me and my environment
that's what you really want to look at
but we're not equipped to do that when
we are
but not in the same way that we are we
can measure ourselves as material beings
that's far simpler and far easier but
it's wrong in my opinion um
one of the great tragedies in my opinion
is that both biology and physics have
concluded that we're here by chance
we're not
that's the consequence of overly
reductionist thinking
um reality is uh wrote a paper about the
homology between the cell and the atom
they both exist in
in a simultaneously in a deterministic
and a probabilistic state and we exist
along that line of identity at some
in some way
so it's not it's not probabilistic and
or deterministic it's both which makes
far more sense to me
so i said well adam it's
it's the homostatic balance in a
hydrogen atom between the electron and
the proton
um
a poly exclusion principle determining
electron spin of the four spin
determinants the first three are
deterministic the fourth is time based
and probabilistic for example
in the cell it's the first principles of
physiology and homeostasis
so negantropy and um hemiosmosis are
deterministic homeostasis is
probabilistic it's the same thing the
atom is
is patterning itself
on the atom they are one and the same
it's they are fractals
um
one of the physical and the other of the
biologic
but i think it and i think i find it
freeing and enabling to think in these
terms because it lets me understand far
better
who and what i am after
what eight decades
yeah so
so yeah but uh but again it's
you you know
you're always in danger of of uh falling
in love with your own ideas
but i i came to them through empiricism
instead of and not through uh deductive
reasoning and so
i guess i hang my head on that and
i would entertain your responses but
yeah i mean this cell is a fractal atom
is a fractal and once we recognize the
fractal relationships
i think we're far
further down
that road to self-unders you know
self-awareness
and um self-understanding and what's the
word i'm looking for uh mindfulness i
think comes much more naturally once you
realize these relationships they don't
have to be taught anymore they just come
naturally because
it's how we roll
or we can if we if only we were to
relinquish
our um
narcissistic um way of thinking about
our existence
and move further into a
i mean
the whole idea of um
you know the tangled you know darwin's
tangled bank that it's all about
competition is totally wrong
that's that's a subset of the the actual
life process the actual life process is
cooperative it's how cells have
cooperated metabolically in order to
give rise to higher form you know higher
to more complicated physiologic forms
not competition competition is cancer
in biologic terms so of course it's it's
it's wrong
and it's dangerous and and we've fallen
into that trap so
yeah
yeah i love how you say both
probabilistic and deterministic um again
it just speaks to the simultaneity is so
important like we talked about infinite
and finite
um or uh god and human
um
and
i love how you talked about fractals and
i love how um when we begin sort of
investigating um
the
like the fractal-like nature of reality
we begin sort of identifying ourselves
as that more and one of the core aspects
of fractals is that they're recursive
and so
when
there's this
there's this um
the self-similar
creation
it
brings home a sense of i am that like i
am all of this undergoing this process
and it
it makes it makes one feel more home it
makes them feel more and at ease in
their heart or like you said that um it
makes you feel more free it makes you
feel like every time that you're doing
something artistically that you're
expressing yourself
whether it's a paper or music or however
people express themselves that
it is in line with that truth
and that it's
serving itself waking up to that to that
truth
um
another thing that i think is really
important that you're mentioning i mean
you talked about this a little bit and i
know that there's like
you know several decades for you of
experience um at ucla and just in
general with like one of the examples
you were giving with epigenetics was the
change of dna expression for smoking
parents on on their children
and then you mentioned
like zygote to zygote and i thought that
was really interesting because i've
always felt like the big bang is like an
analogy to a zygote um
and so i would like to
ask um
when you do tune into that like that
understanding of like zygote to zygote
instead of like adult to adult like the
recursive process is less like adult to
adult as it is like zygote to zygote
like why zygote to zygote why that very
first
like inception of the sperm and the egg
and the formation of the dna itself like
at that point the probability space of u
or i
was
infinite at that point and then over
time
more and more
the
infinite
possibilities became less and less
because we're ossifying our path we're
carving our path more and more in our
trajectory so why specifically zygote to
zygote not only from an epigenetic
perspective but also from
a metaphysical perspective
for the there are two reasons i prefer
the
to
zygote
kind of way of thinking
because the zygote is more consistent
with the singularity
than the reproductive strategy of sexual
reproduction
and empirically gregory pinkus the
person who developed the pill
published a couple of papers back in the
late 40s in which he showed that you can
actually cause parthenogenesis
by extracting
an oocyte from a rabbit through the
tricks that are used uh and then you can
just physically probe that oh that egg
if you will without fertilization
put it back into
the rabbit and prime it with hormones so
it will ingest it and you'll get
offspring which he then showed were um
were fertile
so he demonstrated that that it's not so
much against sperm it's just the
physical disturbance disturbance of the
egg which causes this
flash of light caused by zinc if you
will and that and the disturbance of the
energy state of the of the oocyte so so
it's really all about the unicellular
state all that other stuff that we think
about in terms of um male female and um
life cycle and yeah you know
and to me it's it's i guess the reason i
started thinking this way was because i
thought well you know a mayfly lives
only 24 hours a
you know a great sequoia lives 5 000
years it's just two different strategies
for collecting information from the
environment the reality is it's really
trying to remain at equipoise
not to change
as best you can
and that these strategies of epigenetic
inheritance are all about that
the one other thing i wanted to throw in
was that
um
i find it fascinating
well
not so much fascinating but intriguing
that so we're deuterostomes right we
develop from our anus to our mouth
as opposed to protease stomps they
develop from
mouth
to anus which is the way you would
normally think things would go but
that's not how we evolved
um and so we're moving away from the
source of gravity
by developing from anus to mouth and
that's reinforced by the vagal nerve
which runs basically from your adrenals
through your gut to your heart to your
the tenth nerve of the cranial nerve to
your face to your brain okay
the vagal nerve is actually the
neurologic reinforcement of that
movement away from gravity
and i think that that fosters the left
right brain
which then is what actually makes the
determination of the transition from the
newtonian experience of the organism to
the quantum mechanical the difference
between the left right is actually
the the remainder of that in a
mathematical sense
is quantum mechanical
so so i think that there are certain
these deliverables
i'm of the opinion that our physiology
is not merely what how we are structured
it's actually acting like a lodestone to
the cosmos and and these are
deliverables in terms of understanding
so a balushka a friend of mine who's a
german botanist is shown the opposite
for for plants their roots are where
their brains are they they orient
downward in a positive uh gravity
gravitropic response we we react in the
opposite direction so there's a
fundamental difference in the way that
plants and animals react to gravity for
example
and that there are these fundamental
differences but that the ultimate
uh result is this ability to uh exist in
a in a very robust you know environment
and do it successfully so i just wanted
to throw that in there because i think
it's important in terms of
uh another bite at the apple in terms of
understanding that physiology is is more
than
a mere vessel
for
for for ambulating around the earth and
having fun it's actually the the
process by which we obtain information
and that we have
transitioned away from the primary
principles involved and moved into this
other realm of
you know
of enjoyment as the primary motivation
which is understandable but it's not
really you know it works after fashion
but it's it's coming back to to destroy
us because we don't understand the
relationships between
between body and soul and spirit
uh in that mobius strip paper i actually
suggested that now there are these two
tier is a two-tiered system you have the
binary of the explicit order and you
have the
um
um the implicate order in the in the uh
physiol the cellular mechanisms of
physiology and that every time you make
decisions we're in that space between
the binary decisions and the um and the
moral holistic decisions
relevant to the non-local cosmos
um
and so
as
i think that what we need to strive for
is to be as able to do that freely and
openly and honestly and authentically as
we possibly can
because otherwise we just create this
pseudo existence which is
a faux existence and and it's not really
it's it's not productive it's it doesn't
make us happy it doesn't make us you
know feel good about ourselves as we
were saying earlier we feel like we're
lost by and large because
we don't understand the purpose of life
i think i've provided a rationale for
that at least at a certain level
and in fact i wrote a paper about how
you cannot understand history without
understanding evolution they are
intimately related so now you have a
a pairing of of uh you know
cp snow's two cultures now they come
together the humanities and the sciences
come back together which they must we've
sucked the the humanity out of science
and in so doing we've created this evil
genie kind of thing because
it it it destroys the uh
the humanistic aspect of what we're
trying to do
it's interesting that when you
share zygote to zygote
that
there's so many things that come up that
there's
like the difference between an organism
that only lives for 24 hours
um there's like such a brief just spark
and then there's the organism that lives
for let's say 80 years like a human
and then there's the organism that lives
for
thousands of years like scoia tree
and i feel like that's such an
interesting component like just the
refraction of how a cell can um express
itself in so many different ways and
then also
um
i like how you share that like
physiology
um is like a lodestone i think that's
really interesting so basically like
like the one
uses
um
physiology
to
um
to be able to like understand the
realities that it generates to like
comprehend the realities that it
generates
um so it's like a
it's like a magnet
um
it's like the
yeah
i i mean it's it's so interesting like
the generation of a
of a
of a physical reality
that is then
um comprehended by agents within that
reality
but that
are not separate from it and so it's
still all one
electromagnetic
singularity dancing with itself
um talking to itself being with itself
and i like how physiology is like the
um
it's like the yeah the medium um for it
to be able to
um
like be alive like within itself uh as
itself and um
yeah and that's just that's just a
really exciting um
like realization about biology and about
physiology because it's not a
it's not
um
even like so many scientists that i know
that are so brilliant that spends so
much of their time in their lab
um they're not investigating the
instrument that is investigating the
cell
right so you have to investigate the
instrument that's investigating the self
you have to know the knower of the
experience first and by doing that then
you can actually have a better
relationship also with what you're
investigating
um
i mean there's so many ways to pull that
but that that was an interesting
component i like how you talk about
epigenetics as the very
like strategies themselves i think
that's interesting i used to like
recognize it as like a couple tiered
like a genetics
a
um um
the
the uh like the transcriptomics so like
the begin like the expression the
proteomics
um
protein generation then the the
metabolomics
and then even like the exposomics so
like the way that the genes are exposed
to
the environment and are in a feedback
loop with the environment changing the
way that it's transcribed and expresses
itself
and so then so you call that entire loop
epigenetics is that right
yeah so just to be clear um i mean i
pondered
how
the environment i knew that stress had
to do had something to do with evolution
for many reasons and
i pondered that for years and all of a
sudden i realized that well when you put
stress
it's a little more in less obvious in a
unicellular organism but once you have
the ability to respond to stress which
will all organisms do
um it's known that you they these cells
will generate they'll a sense of
disturbance
and they'll cause a dish homeostasis and
in so doing the cells
will
produce these
radical oxygen species as a consequence
and those are known to cause
mutations and gene mutations and
duplication
in the process it's they will remodel
this the uh that that
uh structure that's experiencing that
stress and the dyson stasis will remodel
until it reaches a new uh homeostatic
set point that's evolution
but we don't see it because it's so neil
schuben's tiktaalik for example yeah we
all recognize that that's the origin of
or thought to be the origin of you know
quadrupeds as they emerged from water
onto land but nobody asked the question
well what's happening to the internal
organs how do you explain that i've just
explained that and that's very important
in terms of that differential between
you know the darwinian
uh description of evolution and what i'm
talking about which is a deeply
mechanistic way of understanding the
nature of
response to stress physiolog
environmental stress translated into
physiologic stress and how does that you
know play out play out as a change in
structure and function consistent with a
with
a re-establishment of the homeostatic uh
or the equipoise between the organism
and its environment
and you can it's demonstrable there were
three
gene duplications that occurred during
the transition from water to land 500
million years ago all three of them are
gene are genes for hormone receptors and
all three of them are essential for the
adaptation terrestrial adaptation of
water you know
bony fish
to become amphibians reptiles mammals
and birds
it's been shown
both in terms of gene deletions
all kinds of manipulations have
pointed to that
and so that's an object lesson and
how important
the the
the antecedents of that what led up to
that
event and then how did it play out in
terms of
adaptation to lane we know that it
occurred it's been documented that the
attempt to get from water to land
occurred at least five times what was
happening during that period of time you
know was millions of years it was trial
and error it was empiric
and how does that play out in the way
that i just described
so it's a known phenomenon but to me
it's fascinating that nobody's put
together
margulis's symbiogenesis
with these ideas until i rolled around
and you know i just
it just
because i was trying to write a review
article about how the alveolar wall of
the lung evolved and then i realized
well i took these two simple germline
cells a mesodermal cell and an
endodermal cell to interact to form 40
different cell types
either that happened by chance which is
fukuyama's
neutral
hypothesis or there was something deeply
some underlying principle or principles
involved and when i did the mathematics
uh and i i tested whether it was chance
or deterministic
in a sense of
you know um it would have taken longer
than the existence of the cosmos to for
that to have happened by chance so the
the default mode is something else was
happening here and that's when i started
to dig deeper and deeper into the that
lineage of cells that you know gave rise
to the lung from the swim bladder or
fish and and working backwards i'm
getting too detailed about it but but i
what i'm saying is
the second book that we published
evolution the logic of biology it
finally is a logic
and i think it's very important it's no
longer anecdote biology is no longer a
soft science it's a predictive science
and i think that has to be recognized
so
sorry about that yeah
so i hope that you know made sense but
um but i mean the evidence is is there
it's just a matter of how you organize
it
it's kind of like you know
you've got this
you've got uh you know this
uh
jigsaw puzzle
and then the question is well how do you
assemble the pieces in a way which is
consonant with what we do know and
people haven't done that um
i think largely again because of this
failure to look at the
deep
dice dyson chronic uh aspect of of
biology
and i have to say that um
what i was going to say is that um
they've been there they've been
handcuffed because darwinian evolution
as you well know
is based upon random mutation i could
never have traced the lineage from the
alveolar
um structure to the unicel if in fact it
were
evolution were a series of
random mutations i would have hit blind
alley after blind alley but that wasn't
the case i was able to find that pathway
by looking at environmental geochemical
and geophysical changes and how they
gave rise to these structures associated
with these structural changes
and what were the cellular underpinnings
of that that's how it worked and does
work
but people are both you know i get all
kinds of i've tried to publish in the
evolution literature and they think i'm
crazy
you know because i'm going against
darwinian principles and
they're scared to death that if if they
don't adhere to darwin then the
creationists are going to eat our lunch
and i think that that's a failure of
imagination
it's really a true scientific failure of
responsibility
to try and think of other possible
modalities but you know it's what put
you know people have to put food on the
table i'm retired i don't have to worry
about
you know not having funding anymore that
those pressures are long
long gone but so i understand that but i
do think it moves people to be open to
new ideas
and the possibility that maybe we got it
wrong
but that's tough so i really do
appreciate your time and
and your way of thinking because i do
think
you express it in a way which
you know i do
embrace
but again i i
always
try to think about well what if that did
happen how would i
is there a testable or testable
hypothesis there because otherwise
as a as a scientist
i can't go there
right
but you know maybe i'm being too much of
a purist
um
but i
you know as i just finished reading eo
wilson's book about the about create you
know how creativity came about i mean
it's beautiful writing but it's
descriptive and it and it's a lot of it
is wrong because it's just looking at
the you know skimming it's not really
diving deeply into understanding
causality in a way which understands
you know how these things
likely did occur as opposed to well this
is a nice
you know imagery of what happened but
it's really not
taking us to the next level of
understanding to to understanding
consciousness you know we all understand
understanding consciousness is
critically important especially at this
stage in our understanding of who and
what we are right
i don't know if i've convinced you that
i've tapped into what consciousness is
i think if it's not exactly right i
think it's close to it because you know
just by
occam parsimony i'd say why would we
have to think about other modalities
than the fact that it's our physiology
that's talking to us and to the cosmos
you know why do we have to invent
um
these
uh
extraordinary um
trans or
out-of-body kinds of things
it i understand why people do it they're
desperate to understand it
but i don't think it's necessary i think
you can still come up with the goods
without having to invent stuff
so my read the book that's come that i
just publium publishing is on hormones
in reality
and the reason i published that book is
because it's now known that the
endocrine system is under epigenetic
control that speaks volumes in terms of
the kinds of things i've been talking
about
why it is that the endocrine system
fosters these kinds of behaviors
and um
you know why we have near-death
experiences or out-of-body experiences
maslow peak peak experiences
um
uh meditation the the results of the
meditative process all those things fit
with the the neuroendocrine
mechanisms that i describe in this in
the chapters in this book
so cool i love how um
we could even begin looking at this from
a
as we synthesize science and
spirituality that even something like
the endocrine system
and the way that if we feel
let's say
more unity
with the cosmos with god with the one
that our
the way that our endocrine system will
um express itself within our body
harmonically
will be in a greater let's say um
harmony and balance and peace
than in a more
um
stressed
cortisolic
anger sort of
style of expression
um
dis ease
right
um
and so that yes so that is so cool so we
can begin
because i can see i basically envision
right now i'm in you know we call this
future presence when you're imagining or
envisioning what's happening in 2030 now
things like that
and so right now what i'm feeling is i'm
feeling like seeing
scientists
coming on board
to knowing themselves as the one
infinite
by
axis points like what you describe where
they recognize that like the because
they're they're such a like you said
there's such a
like a tunnel vision on the specific
thing that scientists are studying like
endocrine system or whatever it may be
and then when they read for example
john's paper about how the endocrine
system is in this
inextricable relationship with the
cosmos um and so then it sort of opens
up a little we could say gate or portal
to the scientists doing the
investigation to recognize that they are
the cosmos themselves and there's no
separation between themselves and this
ultimate power or force
that's so good
i agree with that
yeah i think that
maybe i could ask you i mean i i'm in
communication with
a clinical psychologist who
has
the capacity to read his patients
in a way where so he gave me the example
of some problematic patient who
had a horrific family history in which
her gran the grandfather died in a house
fire and the clinician could smell burnt
flesh
i'm of the opinion that he's actually
uh somehow
perceiving the quantum level of the
person
and so the question is how do you
i mean i understand how the quantum
comes into the equation i just
other than what i said about left right
brain
how is it that we are we'll be able to
uh in a predictive way understand the
quantum aspect of physiology
um
is that just a matter of
practice i mean the way that i sort of
convinced myself of the validity of that
idea about bipedalism and the evolution
of consciousness is i played devil's
advocate and i said okay if stress
is what brought that on
what about a condition where you're in a
low stress situation and i thought of
meditation in the exact opposite of how
the adrenaline affects cellular
physiology occurs in meditation yeah and
medication in turn allows you to go from
burning brain to gut brain to skin brain
in some people i think it's it's it must
be highly
rare to somebody to go back to the skin
brain which is actually the origin the
the cell membrane is the origin of all
our physiology
uh but my point being that
my sense is that somehow in that
progression or that regressive kind of
process
you reach a level at which you are now
no longer in a realm where you're
sensing things in a newtonian way but
now in a quantum way
yeah
yes yes
so
one way to
um
to sense this
is
through
you could say vibration or
um yeah i think that's probably the best
way to describe it um quantum
mechanically so like the vibration of
two entities or humans let's say
um
in conversation with each other and i'm
just gonna blow this up out of
proportion just to make it a point to
make it easy to understand
but
where one human let's say is more
meditative and has a deeper sense of
peace and equanimity and happiness joy
um and then the other human has a
um a strong high levels of stress and
high levels of agitation
and high levels of
anxiety
and maybe even depression and
um this one typically thinks that
they're a victim of the universe and
this one typically thinks that they're
the creator
of their reality and so
then
um
then the way yeah the way that these two
interface you could say vibrationally is
that the creator the more meditative the
easeful one you could say if you want to
follow some of the eastern as well
tradition that the chakras or the energy
centers inside of the body are less
blocked and so in the torus
right of the flow of energy in the body
in the central nervous system up the
actual spinal channel and out the top of
the head
that that
is less blocked but in the one that has
a greater dis ease
those the channel and the energy centers
are more blocked and so the words that
come out of the mouth of the one that is
more blocked are typically the words
so you can sense it bodily based on
vibration but you can also sense it in
the words that they speak
right the logos these words are very
telling of like the state of
the frequency or the vibration that the
entity is at so for example for them
they might speak
in ways that are trying to extract
something to make them feel good
um to make them feel worthy or get some
validation or something like that um
they want to get peace from outside of
themselves and then just to briefly
contrast the one that's more meditative
is typically speaking or using words in
ways that are trying to serve
life
um from an emptier place from a place
that's already whole or already
fulfilled and so you can tell by the way
people speak vibrationally you could say
quantum mechanically
so is the the knower
the observer perhaps i don't know what
the right term is but the one who is
more
at peace with themselves acting like an
energy sink
so yes
drawing out of the negative energy of
the of the
of the observed
yep i mean it's interesting to me from a
physical
perspective because i stumbled onto this
whole um
homology between a black hole and a cell
so this
um beckenstein back in the mid 70s had
discovered he was trying to determine
the
total energy of a black hole
and
contrary to what he had expected that it
was going to be
related to the volume of the black hole
it was actually related to the surface
area
and so i started and
because of the the similarities between
a black hole and a cell in the context
of gravity
um
i always forget this term something so
basically the the there's a horizon
element in the black hole and i i am of
the opinion that the cell does the same
thing in its ideal state its information
its being is on the surface
and that if you are in a negative if you
are that
observed
person who is in kind of a negative
state of
consciousness
that the the information is is uh hidden
but that you can extract it
right through the way in the way that
you described something like that
that make sense yeah
and as as you were referencing earlier
it's um important where
if the one that has the energy blockages
is interfacing with the one that's more
free and does not have the energy
blockages
typically what's happening is that the
one that is more free is typically
reflecting
something
to the one that is more blocked so the
one that is more blocked is typically
asking the one that's more free for this
reflection
and the one that's more free provides
some sort of reflection
that then for the one that's more
blocked they'll like go through an
internal process of
of going to wherever that block is
energetically and liberating themselves
from that block so say that um i'm
speaking in a way that's manipulative
because i'm trying to get people to see
me for my self-image and to think that
i'm really cool
um so then what usually the one that
will reflect will do it will reflect
something
to the one that's trying to get
validation by
through self-image and it'll get them to
recognize that pattern of behavior
and then simply by seeing
that pattern of behavior that they were
expressing
they can then free themselves of that
pattern of behavior and just feel
automatically whole or more free rather
than needing to extract validation or
trying to get people to see their thems
their self-image to feel whole so it's
simple things like that with like
reflecting behavioral patterns um
or um another one so in it and just
briefly also it's because the work has
to be done by the entity themselves the
work is never done outside of the entity
the work is always chosen by the entity
themselves to go into the space where
they don't want to go you know shadow
unconscious subconscious etc and by
going into those regions that's exactly
where
the transformation happens the
caterpillar becomes the butterfly
if you will the metamorphosis happens
transmutation transformation alchemy all
those good things happen
simply by turning to the areas inside of
oneself where we don't want to go
and that if we just go
that then we can actually feel free and
freer in our expression and actually
more in service to life and less trying
to get something out of it
yeah yeah well actually even considered
in that
you know lateralization in the left
right brain
when you and i look into one of one
another's eyes there is not you
eliminate that
left right dichotomy right
so
you know in the
capacity to do that in an authentic way
may not be you know like a switch but i
think it
it has something to do with that
authenticity of that interrelationship
is my sense oh cool
what you just described i mean is this
all coming from eastern vendetta
vedantic um theory or or uh belief
or is this just your own way of
understanding
the inter relationship of the two of the
the two inter you know
uh parties involved
where does it come up from what you just
expressed to me um
i would say um mostly through direct
experience and then um
[Music]
the just the distillation of
um what is most cutting edge about that
possible so
um yeah just the synthesis of all of the
peak of scientific literature as well as
spiritual literature as well as direct
experience with this process
um we have an organization called the no
limit society
we're basically training free agents for
the ignition of global awakening and so
in this process we have hundreds of
people coming from around the world that
are interested in how to sort of empty
themselves of their own self-interest
and their own self-image and their own
ego and shadow and subconscious and
whatnot
and be more like empty vessels
for
the life waking up to itself
and how to like architect out these
nations
around the planet
that are decentralized
that have the basic needs be met that
swim in abundance energetic abundance
awake abundance i mentioned to you
earlier this shambhala and so you could
say it's um it's both like
a
um
it's like buddhist and vikings at the
same time right so you have like the
elon musk entrepreneurial excitement
creation but at the same time you have
the buddhist realized
awakened ones and so it's a it's like
the simultaneity of that um so yeah
mostly through direct experience and
also through
um through my team here through
um the different scientific and
spiritual literature and distilling that
and just parsing for signal above
everything else like
just parsing for truth for signal above
everything else because there's just so
much
um to to try and swim through and like
and learn um but if you find what's most
um salient most relevant
the needles in the haystack if you will
um an accumulation of thousands of
needles in a lifetime swimming across
different haystacks
oh my gosh those needles just compound
on each other and then we can describe
the physics of metaphysical phenomena so
like in this case these two entities one
feeling more free one feeling more
blocked we can actually express at a
scientific at a physical level what's
happening metaphysically and it's it's
so so interesting
yeah
yeah one one thing i wanted to mention
in this context that i find fascinating
is we now know
for example that identical twins are not
identical
but that comes from the fact that we now
know that one amoeba when it divides it
doesn't do so symmetrically so there's
going to be the observer and the
observed there's an asymmetry right from
the get-go
so you know those is that what has to be
resolved i mean each
daughter cell is going to have its own
life experience but then in the process
of
somehow reconciling all of that if
reconciliation is what you know has to
occur then you go through the process
you were talking about something like
that that there's a heterogeneity that
then has to become a or ideally would
become a homogeneity of
the
collective unconscious something like
that so something of that order
it's fascinating to me that you and i
are talking about this from very
different perspectives but we're
really talking about the same thing
yeah
totally
it almost
you know one thing that comes to mind is
you know this whole concept of
the you know that we need to ground
literally electrically ground ourselves
because we we collect too much
electrical energy and you know it sort
of messes things up
um as one ploy to
alleviate the the
you know basins
double bind
for lack of a better way of expressing
it the neuroses the psychosis the
confusion
about you know means and ends cause and
effect
like that
one of the ways to explain grounding
oneself could also just be meditation
itself
and the act of um meditation has a lot
of
um
uh
to be like properly explained is very
important because
just by like calming the mind or like
the fluctuations of the mind
um which is trying to race
into
these different webs like we talked
about earlier there's like
interdependent webs and concepts and
ideas that is a running between
and
we could just think of meditation as the
process of sort of like reeling back
the using the breath as a tool
to reel back the intense proliferation
to a state
that is
more concentrated
focused
calm
and in doing so
there can be a realization
of
who the one that is speaking
truly is
and who the one that is listening right
now truly is
and how that intelligence
is just with itself
and that is just god or the one
and that that's just as simple as it
gets
and that
upon that realization you sort of
you release your attachment to your
individual identity so much
and you can more easily empty yourself
out of everything that you were trying
to get personally
and instead now we can be more empty for
that intelligence to serve itself as
this earth wakes up
and um and there's nothing more freeing
than that anyway but so that that
component to this is so important to
know truly what meditation is or to know
truly what the like the cessation of the
mental proliferation what that truly
gives you access to and i feel like that
might be what you're referencing with
this grounding because we know so many
people that are just obsessively
speaking about concepts and ideas and
proliferating about their sense of self
and their sense of self-worth and
creating separation with other people
that are that have that they have no
relation to and so that whole process
is um
it's like a weapon of mass destruction
really
like um the more than nukes
you could say the largest
weapon of mass destruction is the sense
of self
um
and the sense of separation
um
and so that
if we if we begin looking at it that way
uh we can really quickly heal earth and
heal each other and wake up to peace
unity prosperity abundance for all
when you no longer see a separation
between you
and other
then it becomes easier to only care
about wanting to meet the basic needs of
the whole world and to have everybody be
swimming in prosperity and abundance why
not
um so this is this is where this leads
to
yeah
yeah when you talked about brett i used
to be a long distance runner and
uh you know i used to experience that
runner's high but then i could i figured
out how to bring it on deliberately by
just
uh
uh
sinking my breathing to my heart rate to
my the pace i was running at i could i
could bring it on deliberately um
nice yeah
yeah but but i think it's important to
understand that all this because you
know i've been exposed to these kinds of
eastern thoughts
for my entire life really but i always
thought of that as separate from what i
think about but now
in the realization that that the physio
my physiology is totally consistent with
what you're talking about i think it's
important
to realize it's within us
it's we only have to be able to
realize how it how it functions within
us in order to get everything sort of
you know aligned in a way where now you
are able to interface you know in an
effective way that may sound trivial but
i don't think it is
and you and i both know there
most people i don't think are really in
touch with their own physiology
um they don't care to be it's it's icky
but but if you understand it
in a way
so i'm fascinated by the placebo effect
which i'm sure you're aware of because
i'm i'm convinced that once you
understand that you have some pain
somewhere you can direct
your
energies toward that pain and you can
alleviate it totally true
yeah i mean you can do that deliberately
or better said i think you can figure
out how to do that and and you can
become more and more competent at it in
the same way that you were talking about
the interaction between two people even
within yourself
you can alleviate the dis this
homeostasis the the lack of equilibrium
of your physiologic equilibrium within
yourself
as a proof of principle to yourself
and you know and that there is room
there is place obviously for medicine
because because there are places where
it's not possible for whatever reason um
and maybe that will become clearer as
people become practitioners of their own
of taking control of their own
physiology
as best they can
yeah
yeah
well thank you i mean this has been
remarkable
so cool john
thank you
i mean i hope something i said was
helpful to you i i um
definitely
yeah
and i and i really appreciate how you
um you passed uh like an entire life on
getting excited about
this theme
and that this theme is the theme like it
is the coolest place for you to be
focused on and
um and
like 200 papers seven books i mean
that's that's big stuff to be able to
like there's there's nuggets there's
wisdoms there's gems across all of those
and that that's such a cool feat like i
feel that every time that i um that i
make one of these is sort of like a
little paper if you will and there's
going to be some little nuggets in here
that the viewers can take away not only
from what john was sharing but from what
atlas was sharing and ultimately it's
just what the one is sharing to itself
and so i'm really happy also that you
have and you've been serving in so many
other ways too even like scientifically
epigenetically like for for people to
recognize that like i know i can't like
my children are going to have a higher
likelihood of asthma if i'm spoken
around them i mean just these really
simple things like that are um that are
intuitively simple but then when you
bring scientific literature to them too
then they go okay fine now i can't
screw around with this so
i mean there's just there's countless
ways and that's professing for students
teaching students i mean there's so many
great ways
that you've been serving and so it's my
honor really to to speak with you on
this podcast and to have you as a guest
thank you
i just wanted to say in closing that i i
opted to be a scientist
to contribute to the font of knowledge
because i'm the child of holocaust
survivors
and i'm convinced that the holocaust was
a consequence of ignorance and if
there's any way it could
improve our the human law in terms of
knowledge ba uh
building of knowledge and
realization that there's more to life
than meets the eye that's where i wanted
to be so
but this uh what you and i have been
talking about i think is really
yeah the epitome of what i was trying to
achieve in at a very at a higher level
really
at a more
holistically higher level yeah so thank
you
cool yeah because
holistic is the name of the game yeah
the whole
totally
um thanks everyone for tuning in thank
our audience we really appreciate you
guys
um we'd love to hear from you in the
comments below you can type out um what
you learned from the podcast
any maybe questions that you have for
john
we would be happy to to jump in there
and respond as much as we can
um also uh if the video brought you
value give it a like it helps the
youtube algorithm also subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet also share
the video with others that you feel like
this would positively benefit
um
and also check out the links in the bio
below so we'll have a bunch of john's
links down there and you can check out
his work down there and support him also
feel free to reach out to him if you
have any further inquiries
along his lines of work or his materials
or collaboration
inquiries that kind of stuff
and yeah that's all you can also of
course continue finding our links in the
bio below to the books that i've written
or also to know limit society to join if
you'd like to
and
that's all that's all folks um so john
i'm gonna i'm gonna just go ahead and
end the recording but then you and i
will stay in the zoo room for a little
bit longer okay
sure
thanks everybody much love